[Musik]
hat es geschmeckt sehr gut vielen dank
passt scho geht aufs haus
aber ich bin der böse bruder schon
vergessen aber nicht mein böser bruder
danke konntest du dann mit nico reden
mehr oder weniger wir haben er seit
jahren kaum kontakt wieso eigentlich
nicht
das ist eine lange geschichte ich habe
seit ich bin der älteste und war
irgendwie schon immer der lieblingssohn
meiner eltern
nach der schule habe ich im gegensatz zu
nico studiert und das studium dann mit
einer sehr guten noten abgeschlossen
dann bin ich nach deutschland gegangen
um hier eine firma zu gründen
unsere eltern waren sehr stolz denn sie
wollten einen arzt anwalt oder
geschäftsführer in der familie haben
mein vater hat immer gesagt ihr müsst
medizin maschinenbau oder jura studieren
das hat zukunft und nico wollte das
nicht
nico ist kein akademiker die kugel
anpacken
beruflich und privat er wollte im
handwerk lernen ich verstehe aber das
ist doch nicht der grund weshalb er
nicht mit ihr redet nein der grund ist
dass ich hier nie unterstützt hat jetzt
ist das wieder gutmachen
keine ahnung vertrauen entsteht nicht
von heute auf morgen
ich weiß ich kann warten
seine firma was macht ihr denn so wenn
wir können apps und im prinzip alles was
digital ist echt ja wieso ich hab da
schon lange eine idee